hello everybody hello everybody and a
warm welcome to the opening presentation
in the inaugural lab roots precision
medicine virtual event I'm Kevin Davis
the publisher of caen en chemical and
engineering news the american chemical
society we are delighted to be the
official media partner and co organizers
of this groundbreaking virtual
conference hosted by lab roots slab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
our opening speaker is ruth march from
astrazeneca in the UK for scheduling
reasons we're unable to use to offer a
live recording today we're pre recording
this a couple of days early and for
quality reasons we're just going to rely
on an audio presentation so you don't
have to the undoubted pleasure of either
seeing me or all risk on video but so we
apologize for that but let's get going
with a couple of housekeeping notes and
then I will introduce Ruth for our
opening presentation you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window and if you encounter
any technical problems during this or
any of the other talks are you the
viewing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button which
you'll find top right of your screen or
you can submit the problem through the
green a Q&A button which you see on the
lower left hand side as this is an
educational webinar we're pleased to be
offering continuing education credits
the conclusion of the presentation if
you click on the c/e button which will
also find in the lower left-hand corner
of the web page then follow the
instructions to apply and obtain your
credits so with the honor of batting
first in today's precision medicine a
virtual event gives him pleasure to
welcome all the way from Cambridge
Andrew smart who is vice president and
head of personalized healthcare and
biomarkers at astrazeneca would you like
to get the perspective of a leading Big
Pharma represents a representative as we
hear about a number of different views
and strategies and projects in this
relatively new aspect of precision
medicine ruth leads astrazeneca's team
of diagnostic and biomarker experts
delivering companion diagnostics she's
driven adoption of personalized
healthcare approaches by something like
seventy percent for something like
seventy percent of astrazeneca's
pipeline partnering with many diagnostic
companies in the process she has a long
and distinguished academic background
having worked as a research professor in
immunology and genetics research at the
universities of London and Oxford before
joining astrazeneca and the title of her
opening presentation here today is how
personalized healthcare is transforming
drug development Ruth a very warm
welcome to you
thank you kevin and thank you
particularly for that warm introduction
and i'm delighted to be speaking to you
here today by the wonders of modern
technology reaching out all across the
globe to the community of experts who
are interested in this fantastic topic
of precision medicine or as we call it
in astrazeneca personalized health care
so what is personalized health care or
indeed precision medicine well there are
many terms and my experience is that if
you get ten experts on this subject
together in a row you will end up with
at least 11 definitions we preferred to
start by defining it as to how we see
personalized health care or precision
medicine delivering and it's all about
delivering the right treatments to the
right patient it recognizes that
successful treatment is about more than
the drug alone it can involve a lot of
extra things in archers eniko we
particularly focus on the role of
companion diagnostics and other
biomarkers to select patients for the
right treatments and optimize treatment
it's obvious that this is not an easy
thing to do but when we do it and we do
it successfully it ends in better
outcomes for patients so our approach to
personalized healthcare is centered on
the patient it's integral to our
business and to our values of following
the science and putting patients first
as I said before our aim is to improve
patient outcomes and when we really do
that when we deliver a step changing
clinical benefits
that helps us to deliver value to pairs
and to the business one of the things
that I'll be talking about later is how
we apply personalized healthcare across
all of our core therapy areas and how we
integrate it from the very start of R&D
now astrazeneca unlike some companies
does not have a diagnostic business we
don't have a diagnostic aim on so step
gives us the freedom to work with
diagnostic partners all across the globe
and we work in a particular way to
select those partners who are best for
the drug and for the disease of choice
now as Kevin said earlier we've been
working in this area for about 10 years
and we have reached the stage now where
more than eighty percent of our clinical
pipeline have a personalized healthcare
approach these are drugs that are either
developing with companion diagnostics or
they are actively involved in research
to go down that approach you probably
can't see the detail of this slide I
just want to pick out a few things for
you so first of all those projects with
the green dot that means that they shall
factor flies health care approach I've
seen across every phase of drug
development they are also seen more or
less equally in small and large molecule
algerie Center for you can see examples
in every therapy area and not just in
oncology as we work with diagnostic
companies and other leading academic
centers we are creating a leading
position with those strategic
partnerships we have some of these
examples down here on this side and
again you can see how they'll spread
throughout the globe
so why is this so important you'll all
know that the biopharmaceutical research
and development process is one that
starts off with a lot of medicines
potential candidates that go into the
started clinical trials and reasoning
preclinical development then narrow off
through clinical development so that
only one fda-approved medicine comes out
at the end in astrazeneca we believe
that the solution to this problem live
equality and not just in quantity and we
have published a paper on what we call
for five hours and it depends on having
the right target the right tissue the
right safety and the right commercial
potential for our drugs a central part
of this is selecting the right patients
for the testing of our drugs so let's
take a look at one example of where
we've done this now many of you will
know that these first EGFR inhibitors
drugs like defective highlighted the
importance of identifying the right
patients so in the case of these early
targeted therapies those biomarkers were
not discovered until some years post
launch I believe that the Fed may be
actually took six years post launch to
identify the biomarker EGFR mutation
that is shown on this slide and then the
emerging clinical development showed
that resistance to those first
generation drugs was correlated with the
appearance
secondary retention in the egfr gene and
these were the teeth of 90 and mutations
and you can see here with the separation
between those curves with patients that
were negative for that mutation so for
having significantly longer survival
than those that carried them so what we
wanted to do was to take that
information from the clinic from the
patients have feed it back into drug
discovery to generate the next
generation of EGFR inhibitors so this
diagram starts to show you the fantastic
work that was done by the chemist and
the drug designers here at astrazeneca
to decisively design a new drug that was
would be able to inhibit not only the
EGFR mutation but also this resistance
mutation t790m so you can see here that
sixty-six percent of a quad resistance
is due to the up but t790m mutation in
exon 20 of egfr and it's so called the
gatekeeper mutation so we thank develop
a new drug and it's codename wats 1899
one which was designed to target that
resistance mutation as well as the
original mutations in egfr and if i
flick through here you'll be able to see
how this that yellow portion in the
crystal structure at the top right hand
corner of the of the of the structure
EGFR shows how the original t790m lots
of the binding of the first generation
medicines to fitness and told fever
so the new structure of a 39 through no
one actually is able to bind in a
different place it avoids being blocked
by that t790m mutation and is still able
to inhibit the action and the activity
of that mutated receptor so that was a
fantastic piece of drug design going
into a very early drug discovery even
before the drug went into the clinic as
once we've done that once we learned
from the clinic which understood the
biology and we were able to identify the
right patient population from the very
start of clinical trials this is what
happens this remarkable curve shows you
the overall response rate in very early
clinical trials and all of the bars
layer represents the response from
individual patients anything that is
above the black line at zero is an
increase in tumor size and everything
below that line is a decrease in tumor
size and the cut-offs their show you the
best percentage change from that target
lesion so this is a graph believe me
that you don't see very often in drug
development and the emphasizes the
importance not only of selecting the
right patients but taking those clinical
messages back into the store to drug
discovery and designing the next
generation of drugs the result of all of
that was I'm delighted to say sets a
1599 one now known as Teresa was
approved by the FDA in
member and this was one of the fastest
clinical development programs ever known
to bring but new and innovative medicine
to patients and just recently in fact on
the third of temporary the driver was
also approved in the EU the first class
treatment for patients with that egfr
t790m mutation positive non-small cell
lung cancer the remarkable thing about
both of these approvals is that they
were both linked to the approval of a
companion diagnostic test that was
developed at the same time alpha drug
and delivered on the same day so in the
case of the FDA that was a PMA approval
for a companion diagnostic you can go
and look this up on the FDA website that
was approved on the very same day as the
drug in the EU it's even better because
the approval for the drug coincided with
the launch of a diagnostic test that is
approved both from the tumor sample and
from plasma so for patients that don't
have that chief example available they
can be diagnosed and have to agree so as
a treatment option from a plasma test
will go on to talk a bit more about that
in a minute so what are the new horizons
in diagnostic development and precision
medicine we all can't be joining with
our partners in the evolution of the
next generation of diagnostic
technologies we're seeing a very
exciting move from single markers
through to multiplex testing we're
moving from very invasive procedures to
those with a million basis and from a
semi quantitative approach to pathology
to digital pathology
the future we believe will be to move
more about diagnostic testing earlier in
the patient journey so preferably
patients would only have to get tested
runs at diagnosis and they would have a
comprehensive panel testing that would
then be integrated with their clinical
data and of course this will be
happening across all of therapy areas so
let's come back to the role of
circulating tumor DNA in plasma and how
we believe this is putting patients
first we started to work on this
technology back into thousands of six
when it was something that was being
explored by research laboratories but
some people thought it would never make
it to the stage of being a companion
diagnostic that could be used to guide
therapy in the clinic so we sponsored
some of this research and we now have
the world's first CT DNA base companion
diagnostic as I said before about
twenty-five percent of lung cancer
patients do not have for the tumor
samples available that can be because
the tumor sample was used up during the
pathology that led to their diagnosis or
it could be because that sample is just
not of high quality enough to do
molecular analysis before this
diagnostic was approved those patients
had to undergo a very invasive and
expensive procedure now they can use
this plug the tests which just comes
from taking a normal blood sample and if
they are positive by that test they can
be offered one of our pocketed therapies
as a treatment option
we're also making great use of
next-generation sequencing which we
believe will transform medicine over the
next few years now next-generation
sequencing and we're using a technology
incidentally that was invented in
Cambridge not far from where i am now is
up to a million times faster and more
sensitive than previous sequencing
technology so we are actually using NGS
in clinical trial to select patients for
treatment and also to develop the gene
panels of companion diagnostics in
particular NGS enables us to conduct
so-called basket trials the idea of
these is that patients are only tested
once they come into the clinic and they
are tested with a comprehensive gene
panel and depending on their result they
can then be assigned to the best
treatment for them this helps us to
speed up clinical development and we
also believe that its benefits patients
we're also very excited about the use of
NGS in research so as we look at to
advance personalized healthcare and
bring its benefits to patients in all
our therapy areas we are looking at many
different techniques so I've talked
about the circulating to abate DNA in
oncology have been whispering to these
we're looking at novel imaging
techniques that can look at how drugs
are taken up into the lungs and measure
receptor occupancy in neuroscience and
Alzheimer's disease the use of energy
and pet logins is much more well
advanced and we do have some trials
going on at the moment where that is
used to help select patients to
treatments
asthma we're looking at protein markers
and cellular assays and finally we
usually manage to reveal drivers of
disease in ceylon c vm v that's
cardiovascular and metabolic disease so
all of this wonderful science is very
exciting to be involved in but what we
really want to do is to bring people
together to deliver what we're talking
about to deliver that promise of total I
tell cancer patients and this is where
we rely on the linkage of that drug and
the diagnostic going together now what
we've learned over the years is that
that delivery to patients takes many
partners working together it can take
all aspects of the healthcare system
because we're involving many more people
than the conventional roots of drug
delivery some of the key components
there are putting together of scientific
understanding a diagnostic platform and
regulatory exceptions in all the
different countries that we work all
over the globe putting it into practice
means of demonstrating that value that
we bring to patients and physicians and
obviously the actual assays and the love
infrastructure has to be available at
the point where the position is
practicing and the patience of waiting
for therapy and finally as all of that
comes together the new way of working
can be recognized in clinical guidelines
and practice so today we are looking at
the world where there are more
personalized healthcare products than
ever before just looking at the FDA web
right where companion diagnostics are
listed it's really encouraging in the
way that the speed of those developments
are coming together so what will be the
future for provides healthcare or
precision medicine could the patient or
the future be somebody like this instead
of sitting in a doctor's office with
four other patients sick patients all
together it could be somebody that may
be gone to their local pharmacy or even
they look on suit in the supermarket to
donate a sample and have that sample
treated tested the results of that test
could be making their way by wireless to
the patient's family physician so that
the next time that they call in the best
therapy for them will be already defense
and waiting for them who knows and
finally I just want to highlight to you
that AstraZeneca realizes that we cannot
achieve any of this on our own so we
have a website that is called open
innovation and i encourage you to dial
into that and see the opportunities that
we have to advance research together and
with that I'll hand back to Kevin thank
you so much through for so what a
fabulous opening to our inaugural
precision medicine virtual event a
wonderful perspective and some real
really exciting data included in there
so yes I will follow up with you with it
with it with a few questions I very much
liked your opening quip about you
assemble 10 experts in a room to define
precision medicine or personalized
medicine you'll end up with 11
definitions but I wonder if
what has been your your personal or your
company's sort of responsible reaction
door reception to the the precision
medicine initiative announced from in
the Obama State of the Union just over a
year ago now and I wonder how you what
you how you would react and what do you
feel that's going to lead to some useful
innovation and further funding in this
field thank you Kevin yes we are very
excited about the precision medicine
initiative and we don't even mind
whether it's called post life healthcare
turquoise that's an or precision
medicine any initiative sets and if aims
at exploring science driving the linkage
between tests and biomarker data and
therapy for words really have our
support so we have an initiative in the
UK called genomic England where we are
an active member of the gene consortium
and we also have in the US and the PMI
or precision medicine initiative which
we also definitely support I would love
to see these initiatives really gaining
more data about advancing health care
there are many basic science question
where we need many more numbers of
patients really to volunteer and become
part of getting all of this healthcare
data together what we've realized is
that particularly in common medicines
some of the effects that we're looking
at are probably quite rare and quite
subtle so that's why we need these big
initiatives to actually advance the
science and that's really where we would
want to support these type of
initiatives
the warden see many more of them Ruth
you just interestingly mentioned
genomics England and by coincidence our
very next speaker here at the precision
medicine virtual event is Tim Hubbard's
the director of genomics England could
you say just a little bit more about how
what is the nature of your collaboration
between astrazeneca and genomic England
which as most people know and will hear
in more detail at the top of the hour is
building a large biobank of I believe
some 100,000 individuals yes thank you
so the or involvement in genomics
England was I guess we were one of the
first companies interested as with our
colleagues from elsewhere in the farmer
interest industry in the UK and then
more generally including companies in
the US and globally in this exciting
initiative and we are extremely pleased
wearing the UK government sponsored this
approach to genomics research so as you
said can only exciting thing about it is
that for the first time they have the
largest genomic public-private
initiative in the world to sequence and
to do whole genome sequences of a
hundred thousand genomes and many of
those are from cancer and from rare
diseases we have interests in an inner
any number of fields connected with
these first fourth of the actual
discoveries that I am sure the
scientists and the expert scientists in
genomic think that will make secondly
there's actually how you do a research
initiative like this within the National
Health Service so there's many aspects
of this from consenting patients to
educating physicians to actually get in
the interpretation and the using the
data with international has
health service which I think are
tackling some of the toughest questions
within actually applying coastline
health care so if it does delivered to
patients excellent thank you let me just
quickly have a couple of questions about
a degree so this so tremendous success
story that you've you've led 44 forms of
lung cancer targeting forms of EGF
receptor that have been mutated you
mentioned basket trials Ruth was that
approach part of the the trials that has
sped the development of tickly so is
that something that's come along since
they you completed those clinical trials
so the basket trials and we're taking
part in or we have one in the US which
is called lung back and and actually
Teresa was not included in that the
words from other drugs from our pipeline
that have been included in bout this
it's the same general approach where
patients were actually tested they were
sequence and then depending on the
approach be depending on the results of
that sequencing they would be placed
either on one of our drugs or indeed on
drugs from other companies so look at a
true collaboration that's still going on
at the moment and the other
collaboration that we're involved with
there is in the UK with the stratified
medicine initiative and there the
connection is through cancer research UK
and it's a similar proposition except
that many more of our early stage drugs
are included in that tunnel where
patients can be tested and then placed
onto very early stage trials and again
it's not just a
medicines that are involved with that
that some I believe from other
pharmaceutical companies as well so both
very innovative ways of doing things as
ones which I think are obviously good
for patients because they have that one
testing experience and then they can be
assigned to the best treatment for us to
them but it's it's it would be
interesting how the regulator's then
respond to how you take the results from
those early clinical trial and take them
forward yes and my final question roof
is you mentioned your your interest and
work in next-generation sequencing your
partnerships there's a technology of
course that began at Cambridge with
celexa and then became alumina and of
course alumina made a lot of news at the
beginning of the year with the spin-off
of a liquid biopsy company called Grail
and there are many other companies are
also exploring this I'm just curious
whether given your your the importance
that you've highlighted so nicely in
your presentation regarding companion
diagnostics this must be a feel that
you're you're looking at pretty avidly I
would imagine yes so our or
collaboration with our partnership with
the Lumina is centered around which was
announced I believe last year was is
centered around the development of long
panel test that then can be used in
again in developing many drugs within
our pipeline so it's not yet directly
connected to that that other amounts of
the came out right in January of this
year but if certainly it's still and
again it's a challenging area not just
technically and scientifically so very
much through the regulatory path so
almost development of companion
diagnostics
is something that goes through the SGA
EMA and other regulatory bodies and this
is not always as straightforward as it
might seem once you have a panel of
maybe tens of jeans on the same chest
well thank you very much indeed and
again I apologize to the audience that
we were unable to see you on video for
the opening presentation today but I
trust does that didn't attract too much
and that the information you been able
to provide has really supply the
tremendous kickoff to precision medicine
virtual event that was ruse marched from
astrazeneca where she is vice president
and head of personalized healthcare and
biomarkers for the pharma company giving
a wonderful overview to kick things off
and at the top of the hour our next set
of presentations we hope you'll stay
tuned for those you'll hear from Tim
Hubbard the director of genomics England
just mentioned in Ruth's presentation
and there'll also be a sponsored
presentation from qiagen so you have a
choice and we hope that you'll if you
can't stick around for the whole series
of events running throughout the day
here at the virtual conference that
you'll at least come back for a few more
and this and all of the presentations
will be available on demand for viewing
at your convenience and your colleagues
through for the next six months through
August 2016 you'll receive an email from
lab boots after the event Tony when this
webcast and others will be available for
on-demand viewing so that so all for our
opening presentation we hope now that
you'll check out the exhibit hall and
many of the other features and resources
that are available particularly wants
you to spend time and talk to some of
the exhibitors who have made this
inaugural precision medicine virtual
event possible so for now just want to
thank lab roots and ruse march in
particular for joining us
and we'll see you again for another
presentation hopefully at the top of the
hour so this is kevin davis thanks for
joining us and bye for now
you